- [Voiceover] Part b,
on what open intervals
contained in negative three is
less than x is less than four
is the graph of f both
concave down and decreasing?
Give a reason for your answer.
All right, so f and this should be both
concave down and decreasing.
So f concave down,
concave down.
That's going to be true if and only if
the second derivative
of f is less than zero
which is true if and only if
f prime is decreasing,
f prime is decreasing.
So that's how we can tell
when f is concave down.
I wanna see what do I
need to observe of f prime
because that's the graph they gave us.
All right, now for f to be decreasing,
f is going to be decreasing
if and only if,
we are decreasing when
you have a negative slope
if your relative change is negative.
So that's true if and only if f prime of x
is less than zero.
So both true.
Both true
when
f prime of x is less than zero
and decreasing,
and, let me write, and
f prime is decreasing.
And f prime, decreasing.
So let's see if we can identify that.
Well, let's go back to our graph
and see when is f prime
of x less than zero
and decreasing.
So if we look at less than zero,
let me highlight this,
so less than zero.
I'm highlighting it in
magenta right over here.
This is all the places
where we are less than zero
in magenta.
And now of that, where are we decreasing?
Well, we are decreasing over
this interval right over here.
So that would be negative
two is less than x
which is less than negative one.
So that's we're decreasing
of the places where we are negative.
I'm taking the subset
of where we are negative
to think what we're decreasing.
We're decreasing right there.
And we are also decreasing,
we are also decreasing
right over there.
So that is one is less than
x which is less than three.
Now we are decreasing before x
equals negative two over here
but we're not less than zero there
so I'm not gonna include that.
And so we have our intervals.
So our open intervals.
So we have both true for when
these two things are true.
And so this happens.
This happens
when
negative two is less than
x is less than negative one
or one is less than x
is less than three.
So those are two open intervals.
This one
and that one.